okay as we said last time uh I don't
tell Rob what movie we're gonna talk
about and I was looking for a one to do
this week I see you know I really want
to talk about this one cuz I won't know
just what the hell was up with this fad
that consumed America the early 90s Rob
let's talked about Fern Gully
let's talk about saving the rainforests
and how like that was the most hate the
environment no this was the most
important thing in the world it was in
the early 90s if no kill in a feeling Oh
there were also whales oh yes the whales
not a guy that's at our track yeah Star
Trek force are you thinking about what's
that now you can also use to hunt a
species to extinction is illogical I've
said the human race is logical yeah
whatever give us the whales I'm gonna
come on everybody show that's extremely
logical ah mmm it's all good yeah that
okay you you're obviously older and you
know saying I'm gonna say it was
carefully a 90s thing because I don't
the aunt was about the rainforest
anymore I'm like and it's I'm not saying
on the anti rainforest or whatever it's
just like but it was suddenly like I
know that's you can Sam burn it out to
that crab but it was like the biggest
thing and everything was aimed towards
the kids and it felt like like the kids
will say that the kids will help us and
they never told us how it was just like
the rainforest system point is very very
important and it's being destroyed it's
being destroyed so here's everything
being destroyed right oh my god and
that's like this is what happens when
Democrats take over the White House is
cuz Clinton gotten off is go cuz I was
just so weird like yeah I'm not like I
said it's not anti important or anything
but it's like white the whole world like
for about five or six years was like
rainforests and I'm like okay it's
important but there's I feel like
there's more important things that we
could put in the center and we could be
showing the kids maybe just a
I don't remember it in the 80s as much
no um I like the 80 well that you know
why because the 80s we had other things
scaring us we had the fucking Russians
with their nukes pointed at us well
while we have austrie everything is miss
very much I with a birthmark in the
shape of whistlers mother on his hand
like ndon and we didn't know what he was
about and Reagan was just like group
truth to turn this wall and we thought
the world's gonna blow up and then we
had aids aids everywhere just anyways
gays geez yeah everybody gettin AIDS and
shit and then Wall Street everything was
about making money for yourself and like
you know the huge process outside me it
was a very I think we weren't you being
mean I'm scared and coked up yeah I
sorta have new drug give a shit about
the rainforest um but I feel like once
everybody checked into rehab for drug
addiction Bay became hippies and they're
like the rainforest man that's what's
important the rain for it there wasn't
there was a cultural shift there there
really was cuz yeah I don't global
warming was the next big thing in the
80s I do remember that because I
remember like it was like 1988 I
remember seeing some sort of special in
school and they were talking about it's
like it's gonna be in the year 2000 it's
gonna be a thousand degrees and the seas
are gonna be melting and and I actually
we kind of halfway there so you know
they weren't entirely wrong but it Gore
comes out it's just like later cuz I
forgot about Asia I was like oh we were
kind of right but the funny thing is
like from what I remember from that
special to what we have now I'm like
actually it's not that far off I just
like sighing about it like yeah it's
always really hot around here in summer
it's I don't know know that the climb I
very much believe in climate change
I know the summer that we're from
Chicago with a river still in the normal
we're still in a drought
yeah and it's a hotter we'll ask the
fucking pictures of California would
like the reservoirs that are like down
to zilch now like I mean so it the only
thing that they were not saying because
that
they refer to it as global warming was
that the winters would get shittier I
didn't know that if they vented that
originally all over fixity OHS I have
Chicago like right now he's always a
season off only now are we starting to
not get rain and like May is almost over
so it's like May flat your May showers
bring June flower and yes Chicago
weather is always such where it's like
if you don't like it wait five minutes
oh yeah by me now is five seconds but
her seasons or even our seasons are even
crazier now yeah I feel like from what I
remember as a kid living in the 80s
around here and then the early 90s
really sorry we'll get to forego them
and it's but for what we have now well
you brought up or talked about the
fucking environment it's your goddamn
fault I feel like it's definitely the
weather's crazier now than it was when I
was in it was way more produce like okay
you'll get snow from about this month to
this month and you generally get around
this amount and you always have an off
year where it's a little crazier your El
Nino year but yeah the past ten years
I've been living here I'm like it's nuts
I will say this like it's been crazy
Couture nato's and like like late
November now really here's the fine
thing when you expect the crazy times
now because you know we have really
intense winters and stuff but now it's
like the winters won't get crazy until
like maybe March or something like that
and then we'll add you have an OK winter
so everything's like a season off or a
couple wheels I don't know me news so so
but that's that's kind of nice though
I'm almost like you know global
warming's given us some nice winter gear
ya know and then talked to California
Wrestling we're all do to California or
Australia's and half that all on fire
now or something honestly whenever I
come up whenever I woke up on a winter
morning and it was like actually really
nice and plush I feel like thank ever
global warming
um but no it's still obviously a big
problem obviously the scare campaigns
did not work with us yeah we're gonna
get it's gonna be so many tinfoil hat
types talking about the global climate
change conspiracy you know it's all I
watch comments are just gonna chock-full
of it
no like I I get will get to ferngully
I was skeptical too you know and turns
like the research and how detailed it is
I don't know I just walk out Frigg
inside and it's like this is not the
weather I normally have and we're from
the place with electric already on fox
news serious well the chart at Fox News
so anyway sorry okay charming and Glen
change is the new scare so but back then
it was rainforest and it was just the
strange things nothing to scare that's
what I was saying is it cropped up in
the 80s was when they first opened then
I went away and then I'll go to write
back because of the rainforest thing
like the rain things aren't golly I feel
like yeah it's environmental concerns we
there were two big ones in the 80s
global warming was just cropping up and
then thank you Exxon Valdez like all the
sudden oil companies that became a big
thing because the oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
reactance's only destroy an entire Bay
in Alaska with your drunken captain
ramming your tanker and is it you know
like all of a sudden that makes
headlines but so those are the two big
things but yeah it like the rainforest I
just don't remember hearing about it
much until like the early 90s just like
slap in the face like that everywhere
advent of kit what umpires
fuckin Captain Planet I think like
Captain Planet somehow like you can't
play a lot of that stuff but certainly
but it was like every time Tiny Toons
talked to by Animaniacs talked about it
like every cartoon show that was on at
the time hear some about it there was
tons of movies aimed at kids and it
seemed like we're mostly gonna aim at
kids talking about this so I just know
okay rain for it's important I hate
watching these boring awful things but I
got rain forest important what do you
want me to do about it and they never
said what to do about it
hey hey totally go about planet did turn
off your water when you're done using it
and always make sure to turn off the
light and recycle battles over
rainforest uh so yeah it's weird cuz it
wasn't just being involved with your
hair let's be fair it didn't Captain
Planet I swear to God look everyone's
away
your Congressman did they maybe they did
it's like hints like sushi it's like
Superman though it's like sub Congress
like little Timmy from South Dakota
wants me to save the rainforests I'll do
it yeah
Superman poor care of all our nuclear
weapons um little Timmy is angry um but
yeah so uh and here's the others two
things I was thinking going it does real
thoughts is like yeah what was the
obsession with the rain for why didn't
just take over kids media even though
again it's it's not a bad cause but why
was that the number one thing we had to
hammer into kids I think there are a
number of things coming together at once
one I'm not entirely lying there was a
culture shift I think part of it was you
know we got out of the reagan-bush one
years um I think there was a
consciousness of just coming out of the
80s and we're all just like wow we're
all a bunch of selfish prick yeah we
have you know every something to make
ourselves feel better I the rainforest
destruction was an actual issue like
it's not like that was just made up like
oh no no Anna so that actually was
legitimately happening there were movies
like the mission and stuff they were
talking about the indigenous tribes in
the rain force and that was happening in
the late eighties that like oh whoa
we're destroying the native tribes there
so that happened at the same time you
had this push I want to say it started
in late 80s and early 90s to make kids
entertainment educational like there had
to be some cert yeah that's true so mice
Forrest why why was that the biggie for
kids cuz it's easy but it seems like the
thing that kids can't do anything
exactly what oh oh damn a problem like
alright let's just settle air
congressman there we did it we helped
save them okay now I'm getting it okay
so you sir taught these kids me like no
no educational when really this is the
easiest bullshit save the rainforests
you're done you don't have to put any
extra effort into something that kind of
makes sense we want to do something for
a good cause but we want to it as lazily
as posits it's the perfect California
answer to because it's like
I like tropical paradises I live in
California
I'll help save the rainforest and throw
money at something and yeah you know
it's easier than being like oh yes
I'll get involved in this geopolitical
since you're like what are you gonna do
be like save the Middle East you don't
want to wade into that like ya feel no a
politics and religion and like the
rainforest is easy who doesn't love to
cancer but the downside is the
rainforest is also a little boring so
they have to add things like fairies and
little dry like if there are like you
the kind of dragons in the green point I
mean not like dragons but you don't yeah
and we had to make these mugs monsters
and smoke monsters and stuff um so this
brings it to my second thought about
this movie I'm curious no I'm really
curious to hear your thought on this if
you took out all the environmental stuff
all the stuff about saving the
rainforest and it wasn't about pollution
it was like some sort of magic monster I
just wanted to eat these fairies and
stuff like that everything else was the
same with this have been a good movie
didn't they make that it was called
avatar and that was not a good movie and
that was still about saving the
rainforest and white man socks and stuff
like that I know oh yeah my god saving
Pandora from unobtainium yeah that's
been a good movie uh I was saying I only
need a few major rewrites I don't yeah
does the thing about this film this is
not like especially at that time for all
the rainforest this is not the worst
offender II really is not but there's
you I will say this there was something
about it that I felt like everything
just felt like it just bottomed out like
I did cuz I remember even I would have
been 13 mmm when this came up 14400 been
like 10 or 11 so yeah 13 or 14 maybe in
this movie came in I remember clearly
seeing the trailers and just literally
like as a cynical middle schooler or
like high school with fresh where's
something like just literally looking at
it like this is the stupidest looking
that like it just saying I feel like I
don't want
going to like I kind of knew what was in
it I feel like it just I just got this
me like this is bottom down like the
whole environmental message thing
because you had captain plans well I
just feel like okay we've hit rock
bottom like this is we have played
ourselves out we really happened he I'm
much more we had at least like three
more years of we've we did but I thought
I thought that was the I thought that
was the bottoming out like I'm just like
it's it's never gonna get better it's
just this is it like for me I think is
from here I think then captain plane was
when I was starting to notice that
something when you were getting tired
that's when I was trying to notice it um
and I was circuit and even just look at
the trailers I like I said I didn't know
this kind of a nip Y elation yet with
like you know saving the rainforest and
stuff but I'm like I feel like I know
what they're doing kind of I just gave
up like that's it that's the problem
um and hard to make I mean everything
came out looking like be be nice to your
family that's technically kind of
propaganda okay work with a difference
make it interesting in human and this is
not that so many of these just didn't
feel human even if it's about saving
animals that's fine that's there's a
very resources very easy way to
differentiate the two here Fern Gully is
propaganda Miyazaki films are just good
movies that they happen to have an
environmental message boy like great
like I can I can sit through nos gonna
be like it's still a good story it's
still a good movie and there's an
environmental message but it does here's
the problem this movie feels like it was
made to deliver an environmental message
and not tell a good story Miyazaki films
feel like they're made to tell a good
story that also just happens to have an
environmental message yeah you know
another goodness that's his viewpoint
another great example it's so weird but
that Saturday morning
sonic cartoon a tree head oh yeah
environmental message and it was not
shoved in your face it was very sad I
was a fucking Star Wars story like and
then like we were all wrapped up into it
because of that so it really wasn't
until later I always start looking at
this I just can't get the feeling and
you're right you was focusing a good
source
it was focusing on telling you
a crisper and having good characters for
us even though I mean it I know
definitely showing stuff but it's like
it for a kid show it's still really damn
good um and uh and they I met perform be
really just fuckin fail like it it's
just so obvious hmm um it's not
I can't even say it's quite a strawman
type argument like something's because
I'm like who's the split the sludge like
they are the two Avatar avatars of a
worse or uh yeah avatars are were
strawman because they have actual human
characters that are like but but then
this one it's just I'm a slob drags with
it I I love Tim Curry like he's the best
thing in the movie but I'm just like
what whose idea was it just look at some
sludge villain I did it you know and
with that said because I'm thinking
about when I remember that sludge
villain yeah I'm Eric Tim Curry
obviously I marry the animation on him
being gorgeous and then it always makes
me think the animation this movie is
really beautiful it is good good
animation just go here clear designs uh
and yeah another thing about the story
and I'm thinking like well is it like
okay the back wraps are really bad oh
but I'm thinking of everything else I'm
like okay it's shoving the messages face
but it's like for kiss compasses fine
enough you know it's one of those things
per se it looks nice enough it's
creative you know it has nice
backgrounds and and nice character
designs and you know the characters
aren't the worst you know like I sep 4
the band wrap uh so I was wondering if
like did the environmental side if you
took that out would it be good and it's
like now I'm Catskill a story no no no I
don't think it'd be like quote-unquote
good but I don't think would be ever I
think you would admire the good stuff in
it more if that distracting message
wasn't in there even though I know
that's why the movie was made but it
really is too distracting you're
focusing more on that then the
characters which is what they want
that's not what an audience member wants
you know I think that like you said with
Miyazaki a sonic cartoon it kind of does
it subtly so it's almost tricking you
but it's doing what's supposed to be
doing just tell you a good story with
good characters I wouldn't even say it's
tricking you it's just well in the case
of Miyazaki Lee spent
it's just informed by his viewpoint is
very natural yeah that's his yeah he's
naturally like he's a cranky older
Japanese male who really appreciates the
environment and greenery and like it
just it informs everything he does that
he thinks there's you know like the kids
have lost something to a certain degree
that everything's so modern and like
really like watch him in like the behind
the scenes stuff on any via Ghibli stuff
you can just tell he's like that kind of
grandpa's okay it's not easy yeah yeah
we grew up we played outside the most
beautiful a gentleman from him watching
a like his grandkid or something like he
keeps referring to as a lazy bum yeah
it's just as you know sir isn't she's a
lazy bum she needs a job
and that's where spirited away like one
of those anime sales ever camera just
comes naturally from it I don't see
Miyazaki going like you know I'm going
to convert the world to my view but it's
just he naturally just that we is and
yeah whereas this one just felt like it
was put together by some sort of like
environmental committee like how do we
sell people on this idea and this is one
of the thing I don't need to because
it's really pretty simple we live on
this planet
you really shouldn't shit on it too much
it's not a hard idea to say yeah well
that's what you know you need to sell it
I think you're actually doing something
wrong you know and here's something that
clearly it had um an atom message and
it's shoved in your face by I thought it
was so much more effective and that's
the The Lorax the book not the shitty
movie uh the book and we're leaving even
the cartoon special I thought man did
that that stuck with me so much more
when I heard that story I really didn't
know
I thought trees were just wood with
leaves and that's it you know I didn't
know they had a purpose I didn't know
that they actually did much more than I
was aware of and that movie showed to me
through those visions you ever read The
Giving Tree their purpose is to be
hopelessly there's nothing left but a
stump and then you sit on its face I
feel like a lot of my childhood
literature is just looking at stuff
haha cry but that is virtue that is so
much more effective it shows not only
the downside of all this being gone
because these environmental uh movies
and stuff it's like those show a few
treats being gone or something like that
but they don't want go too far they
don't want to scare you too much and
it's like no go far we we think in
extremes and but not so now I do we have
these visuals of just you knows whole
place destroyed of trees all these
animals walking away and you know these
gray skies and everything but it also
had a solution of you know him giving
the seed and just that one word unless
how frigging powerful is that you know
and so few words in such simple drawings
and he just got the core of what's gonna
stick much more than something like Fern
Gully is going to and yeah fucking
hippie actually I do find it hilarious
cuz I'm sure we're gonna get all these
rads for like people that are just like
Bernabe ing ditch Jakobi shit like what
but this review came out in the Lorax we
got so many leftist like pissed off is
like I don't have it why do you hate the
environment what they just want to teach
us to love the environment and Hunca
tree
you monster i i i wont pissing off both
sides I really do um I just I don't like
to belong to either side I think I just
I just call it like I see it I don't
like to be frickin manipulated so yeah
and what a shock no matter what site you
choose if you choose a side there's
gonna be a lot of manipulation a lot of
lying uh you know and a lot of
propaganda and yeah that's just how it's
gotta go and I don't like but no I I
like being in the middle here shun is
right yeah whoever it is as long as
we're right and they're wrong you know
it it's okay well but this person's a
psychotic maniac run our side so it's
all gangs that's always what I say it is
pure gang mentality you nerd gangs yeah
oh you're gay not just that but yeah you
honestly I mean with nerd gangs and
stuff like that and like politic gangs
it really is such a gang mentality and
yet we're fighting so strong to be away
from that but the only way to fight that
man
that gang mentality is to join our side
hello so that you know what where we are
all right and to figure out who's right
y'all have to find times puppet eyes not
for all of you beat it okay a little
weird place for me to go for that don't
go no Michael Jackson yeah that's good
that's what we should do which is always
tell them that I should just answer in
the affirmative to every you're an sjw
talk you know what you're right like
you're some fucking Fox News watching
cabinet later than you know you're right
and then just watch them fight over that
ya know see that you're really missing
the entertainment one you just don't
give a shit
oh very I think there is so much more
fun when you don't pick a side and you
just watch the ones who are so on their
side
um oh you just sit back in your chair
and just let you know cuz it's free it's
free entertainment but and that's the
thing I think if I was like a super left
liberal or something like that you know
I tried to be defending for going why
has the rainforest and why aren't we
talking about it more this I had a good
message I would totally not see the fact
that I were not a good story with so
many we would kill myself or II sit
there you know we should defend fern
going know Oh a piece of shit Minh no I
know I I you know I do feel a little bad
because I feel like like I said don't
make them drop movie I don't know this
movie did have some good stuff in it
good animation good anime the voice the
voice acting is fine is about two
characters you know the humans and the
Feria trying to female we've seen that
stuff to death it's cute uh the the
actual the shots of the environment
everything are very pretty I still don't
know what that blue hand thing that they
do oh just like I'll throw on a Miyazaki
film any day yes III don't Bobby if
you're wondering like well what's what's
your answer to that you know to
something like Fern Gully and use it
Miyazaki even have freaking sonic car
too and I feel like there's so many
better things out there that can be done
that families can watch and they can
enjoy it and they're smart and they're
lever and they're entertaining never
make it look like you're selling
something yeah and that's the proud that
that's my problem with most of the
internet whatever some because I'm
offended because insert right argument
or left argument here is that you mean
it sounds like yeah offended it's like I
you lost me
I just like it's like you're right
here's something not only awful it's
like yeah that's true when you ever you
say well we imma can do you're saying
this is what I'm selling you immediately
feel like this person's gonna try to
manipulate you same thing but it could
be very same thing with religion I love
religions that don't bother trying to
sell themselves here it's like you know
we'll sit here we'll do what we want
you wanna come June whatever we're good
little more maritime but always welcome
you know the ones that like you know how
dear you know like the pastor the crisis
if you would only believe in Jesus I'm
like you know don't sell that somewhere
else
you know go door-to-door somewhere else
uh but yeah so now that we pretty much
offended everybody that lives oh I love
how Fern Gully brought that out this is
why it's not a good movie cuz this is
what it does it does the opposite of
what supposed to here's the blood
actually uh again maybe you would know
more about this is is there still browse
with the rainforest is that because we
never hear about anymore I think we
played it so much that now it's like a
cliche either summer that it got so
overplayed that people got significant
so now it's all you bring it up people
just go oh that now the problem with
guesses no I was gonna say is it like
what's your problem even more like I
don't know it sounds weird but at right
now Cal looking back like actually now
that it's that stuff is quiet down it's
again can't like the religion thing
you're saying now I kinda want it isn't
it still a problem which is one of the
reasons why I ate like fads like this
cuz they come and they go and then
people forget it's like oh well I guess
that resolved itself no no it didn't it
yeah it's but it's hard cuz when
something catches fire pun intended uh
you really don't want it to go so far
that it will alienate people either
right away or later down the line uh you
know especially if it's something that
is a good cause I mean right first that
is
good cause but it was pushed so much and
so poorly that I think sudden one on the
bright side we still have the rainforest
cafe it would feel yes God knows how
many trees died to bring us that sweet
thirty dollars for crab cakes and I help
save the rainforest do they do anything
like that do they donate anything yeah
it's on the menu it's on the menus of me
but I'd have to look it up the last of
my what there was twenty years ago
because the food was terrible yeah it's
no it's a tourist trap like and we make
it rain and it's like great you turn of
sprinkler systems
that's awesome should a chef weather
animals do a little stereo go it's
basically all they did is the same thing
they do it our jewel-osco grocery yeah
when they hit the water fresh water
there's some announcers like fresh water
misting is coming on and it does this
like little like thunder lightning so
your head on there there is the
rainforest cafe if you eat some the food
it'll be more coming in and then they've
missed the fruit that that is the
rainforest cafe only with you know some
animatronic toucan sam you know and some
trees it's it's like it's like a
lame-ass version of the Tiki Room at
Disneyland that rains on you oh I've
been to Disneyland recently even Tiki
Room is pretty late that's gotta be
really lame um but there are worse
things you could be stuck in the Hall of
Presidents which you only go see when
it's literally raining outside I need to
get out of here
um so watch I'm gonna have historians
I'm offended after I think part of our
founding fathers uh Gabby a name for
like just um we should just make a list
of people we could manage just like
that's all we do we never talk about the
movie we just talk about you know we
wanna offend and it's so easy
we took plenty about the movie this is
okay was this pre Ladner postal it it
was pre Aladdin episode you know this is
when they didn't know how to use the
rabble lands yet didn't know I feel like
I remember after a land they would have
had that
bat character man like Oh if we do
goddamnit okay I remember watching I'm
just like really I I love Robin Williams
and like I thought this would be
tailor-made for him but I'm like I feel
like he's actually not used well enough
they have him rap Robin Williams was a
very talented man he was not a rapper
and uh yeah that's what you did and yeah
I'm count with you in the lab now you
may go they just saw this movie
everybody that worked on fergal I just
like oh he can be funny shit I give a
f--- yeah that's what like everyone
abandoned versus Superman we're doing
when they saw kept American Civil War I
wake up oh that's what we showed up at
they'll take a shot for the drink again
somebody I read a Cabot summers like
take a shot everytime they say BAM every
Superman sucks
take a shot every time somebody says
they're offended hey it's not 16 times
in a row do you think I can give people
alcohol poisoning go for it it's such
it's not success it sucks it sucks it
sucks it sucks it sucks it sucks it
sucks it's gotta be 3/4 uh so anywho um
I don't like the movie I don't think
it's the worst well I guess I do think
the animation is beautiful voice acting
is fine so the characters are okay you
know that the the fairies okay the main
fairy and some of the side characters um
I just Harrington curry do that sludge
is great I guess my problem is this to
me there is nothing more laughable
like hilarious than right-wing
propaganda there is nothing more
insufferable to me the left-wing ha ha
ha ha
I'm not saying very well I'm not saying
right-wing propaganda is like great I'm
saying it's like you just look at and
you're like okay like this but TV ha ha
we have no left-wing stuffs coming let's
swim stuff
like listen it's like that boring shit
on NPR is like oh shut up yeah it's like
the right-wing stuff is the extreme
stuff is pretty fine the left wings cuz
I bet you know cuz I so batshit crazy ya
know it's like whenever they'll Mara
Michael Moore comes on it's like I can't
laugh I can't be like T P one of it I'm
like oh shut up
it's the same reason like I can't stand
listening to Al Gore give a speech but
what Donald Trump opens his mouth is
like so I can't I think we've just
alienated every person uh job well done
i I feel like we've done well um but
yeah so there it is I I don't hate
formally but I'm kind of with you I hate
it I not like watching that movie um I
like do regrets no regrets
um but yeah there you go if um you
haven't tried getting it a flame Walker
down below you yeah you will but do not
use those flames to set the rain forest
on fire that's what matters
yeah you've added nothing to life uh you
want to go like kill a baby seal got one
the catcher then hold it out of me yeah
and I go let's get it